okay hi everyone a very live streaming
day today
uh this is another design review this is
our language
completeness and consistency
review
for things that are hopefully making it
into version 13 of language
first up today is context aliases
okay this is a cool feature let's see
how it's working
all right
so okay so this is
what is dollar context tell us is
right it's an association so you can
extract the key by
uh
right so that's nice
i see so
right the needs create that rule form of
needs creates a context alias that's
nice
that's really nice
and so
let's say if i say dollar contacts daily
asses okay i'll have that
yep and then if i were to edit dollar
context daily asses i can remove an
alias right yep
or you can add more
right okay why is the syntax coloring
not working here but that's under
current limitations
uh so
so the basic issue is that uh
the the front end and the colonel are
not communicating about the state of
dollar context aliases
uh
like they do about the state of
variables
and so for the front end to get better
information it would have to actively
query the kernel in a way that would
draw down performance
so wait a second
i mean we have plenty of things where
when you reset them they cause something
to go off to the colonel and so on
yeah
i'm not saying i don't think john meant
to say that this is impossible i'm just
saying that it it is work that needs to
be done and will likely not be done for
13. i i mean the issue here is that you
need change in kernel state to
automatically update the front end i
know but don't we do that for dollar
context
uh
no
how do we make things read and so on
uh
the uh
um
uh so
the redness mostly comes from the
uh
the you know that we have this symbol
information so that we know
uh
right but we do need to know what the
current value of dollar context path is
so there is there is some sort of state
information that's
traveled between the front end and
kernel but i maybe that's part of the
existing symbol information i don't
remember exactly what's in this i don't
remember for sure if it is or not but
mostly the front end uh
uh
it it changes the active dollar contacts
dollar context uh path for
uh context isolation purposes
um
but
uh
but i don't think that uh
i'm pretty sure my memory is a little
fuzzy on this i'm pretty sure it knows
but look in this case it's got to know
and so you know that's the thing we got
to solve we may not be able to solve it
immediately but it's something we've got
to solve
well i mean you know we've been spending
a lot of time just nailing the basics
here so this is right i mean that's fine
so i mean
that's this is why i wrote it as current
limitations i mean we're okay fine
but yes you'll see yes that's an issue
that's an issue with
it's forcing someone
wow that's not very useful
right so this is going to be as a
practical matter people are not going to
use this as much as they might until
those things are fixed until completion
works and until syntax coloring works
and it's even going to look ugly in code
because it's going to be a lot of blue
stuff there
you know unreasonably blue
okay
well keep in mind
the blue is tracking kernel state
you see blue a lot anyway
i know but you don't the things that are
defined when you haven't actually
evaluated the code i know i know i know
i know i'm telling you people will not
be that thrilled with this until it
auto-completes and turns black but i
understand that's the thing that isn't
done yet
but it's like we caught we can't rest
until that's done so to speak
right but uh okay so let's let's hold on
oh boy
i agree
i think if it doesn't if the alias is
not pulled in
like
like
if the file isn't found if no alias no
file matching that you know to match
that alias is found
i don't think it should create
i think you mean context
yes sorry
wait a minute this isn't the right way
around this is
oh did i uh oh i wrote it backwards okay
my apologies
okay all right okay so i mean the
context if the context cannot be
retrieved because the file isn't found
don't make the aliasing
right
how should we load a package without
adding it to context path or writing an
adaias
right so suppose you just want to make
the code available but you don't want to
modify right if you just call the the
normal needs it adds it to dollar
context path is that a default function
of needs
yes that's how it's worked since version
one
well and documented that way yeah okay
fine if you look through you see all
sorts of people working around it
oh gosh
why don't they just use get oh because
they want to get the the the why don't
they use get a find file
they don't want to do it repeatedly
right needs will only get it if the
context hasn't already been created
so right so so we have force load now
and we have auto load
and at the context path but we don't
have auto load all right so so basically
what you're saying sorry i'm i'm sorry
i'm i'm what you're saying is needs a fu
arrow none
puts nothing in there fu arrow automatic
would put foo itself as the prefix that
you have to use
is that right or is it or is automatic
mean add to the context path
right now i believe none on automatic
behave the same way i mean you could try
it out with uh well but let me let's so
what you're saying is
when there's an aliasing here
okay i understand so so the those cases
the following cases
in a sense
the case that is working right now is
needs a fu arrow and then a null string
in some sense where i mean a null string
artistically because basically what
we're saying there is
that you don't have to put any
contextual prefix before the symbol
right because that thing is on the
context path yes exactly
so
what this is saying
is
okay
so
it could be the case that automatic
means
okay so there are two meanings that we
can imagine for automatic one is you
have to put foo explicitly
but maybe that always works and there's
no reason to even say that
right you can't prevent that one
exactly
so then automatic would mean
i'm yeah i'm not sure that we there's
another sense that we need for automatic
right because we have we have the
just string case which is
load and add the context path and then
there's the string goes to string which
is load and
add context alias and now the third case
is
load and don't add context no i
understand i'm just trying to give a
conceptual thing if it's if it's
automatic means
load it
i'm just trying to make more sense out
of rather than having this very weird
pointy thing of just the nun case i see
so then automatic would mean
add it to the context path
none
means it's not added to the context path
and d me you know or alias means
add the alias somehow to the context
path well you added the dollar context
aliases i understand that but but that
means the access to the thing
where you can still access it as foo
backtick but you can always do that
right you can always do that so that's
it right so so the intended goal right
is that we have you know
publisher id backtick you know
package repository backtick you know my
package which is super long and annoying
to type but you don't necessarily want
all these different
packlet repository
packages conflicting with each other
so you add you know
load this package arrow
you know my short
uh alias and then and i just type alias
spectac everything instead of super long
context yeah right
so so the concrete example is if git
link is a paclet repo under the
publisher id wolfram
then you might do needs wolfram backtick
git link backtick arrow gl backtick
okay
gl
tick
do you need the backtick
yes
in the alias
why would you yes
well we suspect it that way
for consistency
i think we should as a courtesy if they
don't give a backtick i think we should
add it
any objection
we certainly shouldn't do that if you're
manually modifying dollar context at
least no no no no absolutely not dollars
yeah
that seems weird to me to i mean we we
have a notion of a context and we always
write it with a backtick and here it's a
context i don't see why we don't want to
just do it the same way everywhere yeah
i mean like you don't really
right we don't do it for the left-hand
side of that rule right
you have to include the con well yeah
because otherwise it's a file name
truth is with the arrow syntax we could
do it we could drop it on the left as
well
it's not ambiguous
look i minorly think it's worthwhile i
think you guys will want it at some
point but i don't care right now okay um
okay so
um
okay so we're none means
don't have it's the context path
automatic means with the behavior that
you see right now from needs and a
specific alias means
add that alias make it according to that
alias okay
ignore context aliases
should information
right so if you look at the
documentation of na of names right there
there are these ignore case and spelling
correction options
that we currently don't support in
information
uh right so
and right and you can try this
right now in in that notebook right you
could do names of d backtick star and
you'll get
uh
um
you know all the developer context
symbols
um okay
and but you could also do names uh d
backtick star
ignore aliases goes to true
right so you get lots and lots of
symbols now if you add the option ignore
context aliases goes to true
also um
well it's reddening because we haven't
defuturized the documentation yet
um
what does ignore mean oh ignore as in
discard context aliases that's the wrong
sense of ignore
okay
ignore case
means
i want it
you know as an equivalence class
of k you know equivalence class in those
cases you get what i'm saying
no this is not ignore and in fact to the
contrary
it's
well it depends on on which way you're
looking at it if you're looking at it as
something that's looking in the symbol
table this is saying don't also look at
it it's saying don't resolve context
aliases right
so it's more like resolve context
aliases arrow true or false
okay yeah i i would be okay with that
right we'd need to negate the sense uh
for the game but
that seems perfectly
fine to me the chris john any objections
thoughts on that point
i think objective
i think the reason that i chose ignore a
case was because or sorry ignore context
aliases was because i was
doing something like ignore case is it
names that has ignore case
yes no names just look it's equivalent
capital and lowercase
a
that's what it means
whereas here it's either you turn that d
backtick into
you either resolve context aliases or
you don't and you insist that they have
to be
actual context so to speak exactly
i'm just worrying okay my my worry here
is the name resolve context daily asses
i could imagine
that we need a function that is called
that
that goes from i mean in other words if
i have d backtick
packed array q
is there any way in which i how would i
get the resolved version of that
you would just evaluate it on its own i
i don't know
if well string would be names right
right yeah
oh okay fine
all right resolve context daily asses
arrow true or false seems fine to me
default is true
the fault is that you are resolving
context daily assets
right so you can use them right right so
we're right so we're adding this to
names to contexts
to information
and so then i noticed well
names has these two extra options the
spelling correction and the ignore cases
um
that uh
information does not have and so i
probably should have those it should
probably get added i've got another case
which is the symbol symbol
that we want to ignore do we want wait a
minute what do we want to do that
evaluates that symbol that evaluates so
i don't think
it obviously will resolve
no if if you say symbol
of d back tick packed array q
why does that resolve it becomes the c
it evaluates it becomes a symbol on it
right
well i think that this was
uh
um
but wait a minute wait a minute wait a
minute how could you have a d backtick
which does not resolve the the context
alias if if i have a context called d
can i get that's when i want to try to
get to it you you cannot
and if you try to create a context
so i think this is uh
partly discussed in some of the next
points but basically it's
um
you know it uh disallows
uh
you get a warning if you create a
context alias that shadows and exists
with symbols in the case of resolve
context aliases i don't understand what
it can possibly do if you say don't
resolve context daily asses
there's nothing to find it'll just come
up back blank
because it doesn't find the raw dibactic
whatever
right i mean i guess i guess
our thinking was
you in the symbol case we could possibly
add that that option
um
but i mean certainly we want the default
behavior to be
you know symbol
law is no different from typing that
thing in i agree the defaults should be
that right but i'm trying to understand
if d is a context on its own
you're saying it is forever shadowed by
the alias is that correct
um
yes
until you remove the alias
you know i have so many shadows of the
smp syntax modification function
well and and keep in mind that
oftentimes the way that you will use uh
context alias is in a scoped fashion
uh
so if you declare a context alias uh
inside of a begin end block uh when you
hit the end block it's going to
revert
changes to
uh dollar context dailies okay you
didn't say that here but yes okay
i didn't know that about begin end
and hopefully in the new package
scheme it'll be even sleeker in the way
that it does that
i would hope so but i can't directly
speak to that
okay
having an alias context path context
daily asses and creating errors which is
equal to a member of context path
right so i think this
right so this is the issue of
um
you know clashes between things so we we
put in the rule that
uh well
i guess this started with
you know context aliases are aliases
they're pointers to context they're not
context themselves so we shouldn't add
them
you shouldn't set them as dollar context
and you shouldn't add them to dollar
context
path
um
and you know partly you know that's just
sort of
you know because type mismatch and also
partly the you know you run into
interpretation issues yeah we don't want
that we don't want that we just want
them in context aliases as opposed to
context path exactly
um right and so
and then earlier iterate and i think
what's cr
then there's the second question of well
suppose you already have something on
dollar context path and then you add
a context alias which is equal to one of
those
entries on dollar context path should
that also be disallowed and my viewpoint
was
absolutely that's just basic consistency
now chris cooley had some objection to
that which i can't really articulate
currently you can you can overwrite
right i mean context if you set the
context alias
if you use the context alias even your
needs is not going to fail
just because you have a context called d
your needs blah arrow d will not fail
right it'll just create a context alias
let me say that again
let's say there is a context out there
called d it may or may not be on context
path
okay
you say needs blah arrow d
you're going to create a context alias
called d
correct whether or not there was already
a context called d and whether or not it
was on context path
therefore what i think should happen is
that if you
try and add
two context daily asses something which
is already on context path i think it
should give a warning but work that's
what i think
and does it shadow
yes because that's what it does in this
case and and and then my next question
is
suppose suppose the um existing d
is there because
it was added to the system and there's
some system function that's going to
call you know d backtick some important
function
then because that system function was
loaded before this needs
with the alias
um it will still be calling the correct
important function right correct yeah
okay because right so because closing is
already really
right contexts are only resolved at
symbol creation time so once once you've
hit shift enter and
the expression is parsed
you're done and you know so if the
definitions were created we don't go
around and start changing the symbol
table that's
that's the whole point
yeah perfect just wanted to confirm that
way lies madness
yeah
okay
should we disallow aliases that match a
strict subset of dollar context
i don't see why
i don't understand why we would do that
oh my god what is this
uh this is uh oh my god
i we don't necessarily need to go
through all of these uh this is just
you know we yeah this is not an agenda
this is chris's carefully curated
set of you know all sorts of edge cases
and and principles and things like that
we spent probably half a dozen meetings
resolving these things so that you
wouldn't have to right you're right i
mean the this is there in case yeah yeah
this can this this list is there so
should we need to refer to any of these
things i have you know i have one of
chris's nicely curated examples handy
this was not something we were doing you
got a big list for possible issues at
least
yeah
um yeah you should this may be the
longest possible issues section in the
whole documentation yeah i i don't think
these are all possible issues but uh
yes i mean
my head is spinning i'm not going to
look at these unless unless you think
there's one i should no no you don't
need to
but let me just ask chris chris is there
a decision that has been made so far in
this meeting that you don't agree with
well no but there's just that last
question i don't think we completely
resolved it because there was kind
you know if you scroll up there was like
that that last
uh
right so that was
yes we we we decided that's like
we are going to allow creating an alias
which matches something that's already
on context pat
and i guess context but
then
there's also that other issue where
you know we're sending dog context
you know to something or adding
something to the context path and you
know the question is
right right now
we disallow adding an alias or a
subcontext of an alias and the question
is just you know
is that the right behavior or do we just
want to match disallow i'm sorry just
disallow adding to
context
a
what we what we said before is
we will disallow
the adding
of a context
that conflicts with an existing context
alias correct
well adding to context path
something which is an existing context
alias
i mean you're already going to get
confused if you had a context out there
d backtick
and now you create a context alias and
then you say dibaktic and you thought
you were going to get the off context
path usage
of that thing but it's not the off
context path usage it's instead the on
context alias usage
see what i'm saying you see the scenario
yeah and
that's the that's the other
word yeah right well yes so so that that
is something right that
we just need right so you do get a
warning if you add a context
alias that clashes with an existing
context you do get a warning that says
you know the original context will be
shadowed until you remove this context
okay so any context whether or not it's
in context path right then what we
specifically prohibit is adding
a
context alias to the context dot to
dollar context path
or setting it as dollar cost so that's
the other way around so that that's
saying
no no no
that's a more restricted thing then then
there's also the question of the other
way around no look if if you type in d
backtick whatever you're gonna get the
the
okay a symbol that doesn't exist already
okay a new symbol new
i've done a context alias for d backtick
now i type d backtick new equals seven
that will resolve
because it will resolve the context
alias to develop a backtick new equals
seven correct correct
okay
okay so the case you're talking about is
you have a context daily ass and you
want to add to context path
something which you will never ever see
because it will always be shattered by
the context daily ass
correct
correct
right so that's why you would
may or may not exist even right
well that's fine but i mean but but the
point is you'll never see it because you
add a code to context path thinking
you're going to get this context but no
you're not because it's going to be
grabbed that sequence of characters is
going to be grabbed by context alias
well
if you added the context path
and the symbol and you can reference
existing symbols in that context right
that's the point of being on dollar
context path
yeah by the way what happens if you say
foo arrow foo in the needs
it'll just be happy i mean will it enter
that as a context daily ass will it just
say
be happy i don't need this as an alias
well it'll enjoy it isn't it currently
yeah right and
aliases can only be one level deep so
it'll only work if it's a one level deep
context
all right so look the sub-alias the
sub-context thing i don't understand the
significance of that
so the chris do you have an example
about that here
you basically you right because we
replace the leading
thing right so if if if you do d
backtick
a backtick x
then you'll get developer backtick a
backtick x oh i see i see that so that
that that is why
can you but you can't alias the d
i'm sorry the a you can't really sda
correct but you could alias the dibactic
a backtick
yes at the moment what's that
i mean
it's only it's only kind of like
completely ill it's because of the fact
that you have an alias from d to
something else but you can't you can't
have an alias called the baptic a baptic
um for very subtle okay but
goes to df
can i do that yes
yeah that's fine because itself is just
one level
right so
aliases cannot be multi-level aliases
right now by the way notice how i didn't
put the backtick on that second thing
i'm telling you you should let people do
that
should let people not put the black tick
anyway i mean
okay i mean the main point is that you
don't allow people
to
end up you allow people to peel off the
front
but you don't allow people to kind of
give second level aliases for the
you know the foo here
in other words you can you can alias dev
fu
but you can't alias foo on its own
that seems right
yep
right okay and and and the point is
right if you did
if after you did this you did you know
df backtick a backtick x then you'd get
dev fu a x exactly and so then the
question is
given that you can potentially be
rewriting
you know sort of the front of a context
do we
that was
the motivation to disallow
the
you know not just think or at least warn
about not just things that are on
context path but also
yes you know sub-context i think we
should warn
okay
right
well good work here
any time somebody's working
one last question are we warning for
both directions or you know
you know
by directions i mean you know if you're
adding an alias to dollar context is
that disallowed or warned versus the
other you know versus adding analysis
it's already on the context path that's
i think we decided that's worn but
it's the other direction also just worn
wasn't there one we said we disallow
previously for a one level context what
was the case we said we disallow
adding a context alias to dollar an
existing context alias to dollar context
path
right because it will be a guaranteed
shadow
right so is there any case here where
it's a guaranteed shadow
[Music]
okay if there is disallow it if there
isn't don't okay no just one
okay do you want to take a look at the
rest page at all
i'll look at it
this is mostly on needs right no it's on
uh
seller context aliases
we we need to update neat
yes yes but i didn't want to do all that
work until we made all the fundamental
decisions
so
i forgot to commit the latest version of
this so there's some bootstrapping stuff
in here
that's why i mean this looks fine
yeah
yeah but uh but yes i will touch all of
the other things you know names uh
symbol
uh you why are you doing this john it's
wonderful public service but why exactly
are you doing it uh i'm the one who came
up with the core design and i'm the one
who who pushed for this problem to be
solved in the first place okay well good
for you i just love it i know i mean i
will and i will also be doing a portion
of that it's not all falling to john
okay is that python inspired john
uh
it's
it does come from python but it also
comes from javascript uh
javascript does something very similar i
see
it's a good idea
there it is
all right
i mean one question about it is
the standardization of you know whether
we should actually say
in and this is a question for paclets
and things like that whether they should
say
a typical shortening is blah blah blah
that might be helpful to people i think
that'll oh oh oh actually that reminds
me of one thing i wanted to bring up
which is that
you know we have this convention and
it's i don't know if this convention is
actually
written down anywhere but
virtu nearly everyone seems to follow it
that
uh that context names
typically have initial caps
um
we might want to promote a convention
that context aliases
typically don't have initial caps yeah
yeah i like that
we've all been using that you know
examples and thinking
right so just use the examples that way
and we we could
we can make some comment but nobody's
going to read it in the context of
aliases documentation
if we have a workflow about context
daily assets we can talk about it there
all right well done looks very good guys
all right so on to the next topic i
think
so people who are
here for context aliases are welcome to
drop out or they can stay and hear about
matrix form okay i'm i'm i assume you
probably won't need me for anything else
so i'll drop out right okay okay so this
is this is making this a more rodent
more like a rodent linear algebra more
like a rodent
can you guys update to me i mean this
was triggered in an lcc meeting before
which i wasn't at so i don't really know
the background
uh
yeah i don't know that uh
there was a lot of background to this it
was just something that why the hell
does transpose not work through matrix
form
that's weird uh because it works it's
not a linear algebra function it works
on lists it works on associations
nobody's having combinations
nobody's ever gonna understand that
right which is why i think making
which is why i think making things
uh
rodentify you know go through matrix
form is just wrong we have the technical
term rodentify
what does that mean
be like a rodent gnawing through
things together okay
um
right so
you know i
think you know i think modifying matrix
for or modifying things to go through
matrix form is the wrong thing
um
i mean are you saying that the ones down
below here
have just been made to work or have
worked for millions of years
there exists a branch which may not even
be in the prototype build which makes
them work by sort of
you know modifying the the sort of the
is this a matrix that can be eaten by
linear algebra functions all right all
right fine i identify okay so the people
who are most keen on this are the people
doing elementary math
so are they represented here
the wayne crowd and people like that
i think that there are lots of people
that are keen on this
particularly if we have an updated
matrix form
that scales a little you know scales
pretty well
but i don't see how we can do it without
having a matrix type that's the thing
it's like
um
because we can have lists of lists that
can be matrices but are not matrices
well i mean this is like having a sparse
array where things go sparse to sparse
in many cases
but don't guarantee to go sparse to
sparse they might despacify
right and so i i am suggesting what we
need and this was actually rob's
suggestion which i think is a good one
is we need a new type of structured
array which
basically can have any type of data
inside of it but
is you know formats and matrix form
always
and then sort of oh boy
you know i i a term that i've often used
with tom
is
you know the pumps are starting up
the ship is sinking
we're adding more and more pumps to
keep the water out
now i i think
i think it's a little bit the timing is
not quite right to have that but that
would work
but the the main thing the name is not
the right thing i mean it's the the the
framework name is what that is
um
that that could work i mean that would
work
i mean you're saying a thing called
matrix basically
basically
which is something that formats is a
matrix it walks and talks like a matrix
it has part extraction like a matrix
absolutely does transpose like a matrix
it just happens to format not like
not as you know it
you can treat it just like lists of
lists
but it formats differently as a courtesy
so to speak yes
yeah well that's an interesting concept
i mean i think that will become a lot
easier when the compiler is used in more
places
well that too this fits this
that that's dr array
fits with the compiler
right i think this is a future thing
then right yeah i i'm just saying
you know i mean if you look at my
example of the contradiction like we
can't make matrix q of a matrix form
thing return true
right that would just listen listen it's
too early roger is right this is not a
thing for right now okay
it won't be too far but but we need to
just progress a little bit and i think
it's going to be possible and we're
going to have a very constructive
discussion
and i would wonder if it should really
if it should be restricted to rank two
or is it already not we can have that
discussion yeah let's have that
discussion because there's a lot of
things matrix form itself i think is
pretty old i'm guessing from version one
it is yeah and and
it
there's a lot of things needed for it so
well which we could put into matrix form
itself but absolutely we can absolutely
we can
but but if it's going to be showcased a
zillion times if we wanted good
yeah yeah right
right well for sure but i mean but i
mean even things like band matrices i
don't think they format in a special way
blah blah blah blah blah
there are lots of things that should be
done
better in matrix form
matrix form was built at a time when we
didn't
expect to
but but but for instance here's super
simple idea things
the way that numbers format in matrix
form makes them look very ugly in our
system
and much more primitive system makes
numeric matrices look clean
yeah other use cases that you have in
elementary math is you often want to
highlight pieces of a matrix like a row
a column or sub matrix
or you know entry
um
so that the the pretty basic things and
then you're saying like matrix form
having having the number precisions
agree and all that kind of stuff right
we've never we didn't worry about that
right the third century we didn't go we
did not worry about that right
and and
uh how was it yeah the other thing is
that one can do is to make it degrade
gracefully when you deal with bigger
matrices
you know by by
by aligning things for instance we have
to do a bunch of experiments but it
would be nice if it didn't sort of just
not work particularly well
right
okay fair enough yeah and i mean about
sort of the vector and i mean i
explicitly addressed the
vector and elementary user case right if
we had a constructor right you could say
head of you know something vector hue
comma row matrix
or i guess just sort of
we do it okay
let's not get into this yeah is there
anything else that we have coming up for
um
there was something that i just sent
along to lcc
about
uh find fit we uh is
rob should be here so we can have that
conversation about
well i mean look the basic point is i am
absolutely fed up with
i i want to fit
and i want the fit
right i don't want
so
i'm gonna have to run here in a minute
but for distributions we did two things
there is estimated distribution that
gives you the object a distribution and
there's fine distribution parameters to
give you the rules parameter goes to
value
so we did two things
um
maybe we need an estimated fit or an
estimated
you know
something like that why just not add an
additional argument to find fit
yes that could work too well we could
say that's what to begin with
i mean what we did recently was he added
properties to fit that allowed you to
get out the the values or the rules or
the this or that and maybe fine fit
could do something similar
right well okay so the issue is this i
want to do that that's what we were
talking about properties rob like this
right so i mean the issue is this the
issue is this it guides me absolutely
freaking crazy that i go a plus bx here
i say a b
x dandy okay i get that out
i don't want to get that out i want to
get 2 plus
bx sure you want to get your model
function but but fit used to only give
the model function which is really
useless if you wanted to actually get
the parameter values so so that's why we
added the property so i think properties
is the way to do this
why does this say fit
well
fit only does linear fits
and they think you gave it too many you
need to give something like one comma x
comma x
list of one comma x yeah okay but so
that's a really primitive thing which we
also need to fix
well we we have to some extent we've
we've
no we haven't we've made another
function
no no go go
that does that
matrices and see the prop case there
right
right so
well i never used that i've never used
but it's new
if i but i but i this is a linear fit so
i want to do an exponential for example
right so we're just saying fi we need
that same argument i mean to the ex to
the extent that
this makes sense
yeah then it would be a happy camp of
the time that's what we're proposing
yeah okay let's do that right now
that that should be very easy let's get
that to happen
and that way and that's useful too best
fit pure function that seems useful too
yeah
so we will do a similar proposal and
we'll
okay
okay great
by the way fit fit has been
highly modernized with regularization
tests of all this advanced
regularization if you have to become a
better fit
yeah
exactly
yeah
okay that's good well i mean so does it
take weighted data and things
yes
it doesn't say that here
doesn't say that anyway here
well let's see i can't remember how you
put the weights in but well but you
should just know maybe
data
yeah
should say weighted data right
yeah
let's let's go back and check on that
rob and then make sure we actually don't
yeah i think i'm pretty sure it takes
takes weights but
i gotta run okay see you guys okay
thanks and uh
see you all later
bye for now
hey brett do you have a minute to join
my zoom